日本語アドバイス第8回ん
第8会
8回あ近い
アドバイスしている場合どのようなこれすき家の食べすぎってありえる
嫌いになってしまったらもうすき家じゃなくてキラやなっちゃうから嫌いにならない
程度で食べたほうがいいと思う日本のコンビニに入ったことがない行ったことがないの
でちょっと入るのが怖いんですが何かアドバイスありますかそうだよ
ね日本のコンビニって入ったこともなければちょっと怖いんだよね
日本独特のものっていうかアメリカのコンビニとはもうだいぶ違うからちょっと怖いっ
ていう気持ちは分かるんでまあ一つのう
具体的なアドバイスとしては中国のものだったと思うんだけど
包み紙もう丸ごと食べていい
雨があるんだよねで日本のコンビニで売っているおにぎりはそうじゃないんだよね
経験でわかる教科書とかじゃなくて教科書とかじゃなくて
日本人向けの本とか映画とか
a いわゆるまあアニメとかっていう初心嫉妬を使った方が効果的っていうことはあり
得る
a 僕はどっちかって言えばもう今までは wii ビシッとしか使ってこなかった
から
ウイビシッとでいいと思うやっぱりなる頭がいいね感じを切る
a に書く方法まあ衝動の竜児みたいに
書きたいんですけれどもその方法を教えてくださいこれを質問前の動画でもすでに紹介
しているんでええ
その動画の一部をここに入れておきますね
日本在住の外国人でどのぐらい日本も文化を尊重して行動をとったほうがいいでしょう
か
つまり日本人と同じような振る舞いをした方がいいでしょうか
いい質問だなでなんでいい質問かというとこの質問している時点で日本人と同じような
考え方を
持っているから周りに迷惑をかけないというような
心が見えてくるからこの質問している時点で問題ないと思う最近 trash テイスト
それにクリスブロート
はデュオリンゴについて
色々言っていますが道元さんはこの日本語学習ツールについてどう思いますかそうだ
なぁさっき言ったように僕はいわゆるういーぶしっとしか使ってこなかったからなんと
も言えない日本で今点数のクリエーション
をしたいんですがりさーはどのようなものを取った方がいいでしょうか
どのような日さあがふさわしいでしょうか多くの方は多分
分館 visa もしくはなんだったかな人運ブーンチスキビさを取るべきだって誰も
持っていると思うんですが実はそうじゃないんだよね配偶者庇かな日本語のアクセント
を教えていますよね
どんぐどの時点で日本語のアクセントを勉強すればいいでしょうか
場合によっ
で勉強しなくていいと思うんだよね勉強しなくても実は伝わるんですよねほとんどの
場合はでもやっぱ
ネイティブと同じようなしゃべり方をしたいのであれば
まあできるだけ早く今日から僕のぴーちゃーん成立を使った方が良いと思いますでない
と危ないから日本引越付
時って
何か準備するべきものはありますうーん心も準備くらいはした方がいいと思う物理的な
ものだったら
を全部百均で買えるからひらがなカタカナんそしていくつかの漢字を覚えることができ
ました
できましたが文法まだ苦手です
どうしたらいいでしょうか文法が苦手文法案に負け
すいません僕に聞かない方がいいみたいです留学
今度日本にしたいんですが何かアドバイスをください
留学につけているアドバイスをしてください教室って勉強するよりは外に出てそこら
へんの日本人と話した方が話した方が効果的だと思います僕は
そうしてまーそれにウエーブ嫉妬を使って日本語を勉強してきます
まだわーとかの違いが分からないんですねあとはできるだけ何度もたくさんたくさん
食った方がいいと思うなんでかっていうと
自分の国に帰ったら多分美味しい飴はないか後悔しないようにねこんにちは私は4年間
日本語を勉強して園2
取ろうとしていたんですが途中で辞めて今もう1回勉強しようかなと考えています元気
をもう1回最初から使った方が
いいでしょうかそう考えるとちょっと気が遠くなりますの中には一番今必要なのは
モチベーションだと思うんだよねやる気だと思うんだよねだから一番の教材は間違え
なく
進撃の巨人の op 打倒もそれを聞いているとどんどん
どんどんやる気が湧いてくるはずシーズン1でも2でも
へ構いませんなんといってもウェーブ嫉妬は正しい発音で日本語を話すことって重要
でしょうか
正しくない発音で話していたらバカだと思われますか
いいえ発音を勉強しなくてもうあなたは天才だと思う
れるに違いない a 最も良い話し方って
何を教えてくださいリヴァイ兵長と同じような
話し方がいいともまったく出来てねあでもエルウィン
男女もかっこいいなど近いのかな知ること
今日は道元さんへ大ファンです
アレックス今日は自分の日本語を評価するとしたら
日本語上手それとも日本語うまい
モスクワ日本語の発音がいいどっちになると思う俺の日本語土地家庭やは多分上手だと
思うんだよね
まあなにしろそ日から上手だからですね
ni